معنى اللي هو فايز الدويري الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي ضيفنا من عمان فايز
باخمه التي الذي بخمت اعلنت السيطره عليها
من قبل فاجنر وليس من قبل الجيش الروسي
الاوكرانيون ما زالوا ينفون كيف تقيم
الاخبار التي تتحدث عن السيطره بالكامل
على
يعني يوم امس كان الحديث ان ما تبقى اقل
من مربع 900 متر في
جزئيه ساموليت وبالتالي عندما نتحدث عن
مدينه عدد سكانها 70 الف عند بدايه
المعركه والان الحديث عن مجموعه من
المباني في الجنوب الغربي فهي باعتبار كنا
نقول بانها عسكريا س اكثر من شهر
والاعلان عن سقوطها لا يقدم الشيء الجديد
لانها بحكم الساقطه ولكن انا اعتبر انما
الاعلان من قبل
بريجوجين قائد قوات باتنهر هو نوع من
النصر الشخصي هو يعلن عنصر شخصي له
ولمجموعته وقد
اشارت ان الفعل الحقيقي وعمليه
استعاده او السيطره على فخمه كانت فقط من
قبل قوات فاجنر وان الجيش الروسي لم يساهم
وبالتالي هو هنا كانه يسجل انتصارا شخصيا
كقائمه مجموعه
مسمار القتال فهو القتال ان لا يجوز فهو
في مجموعه الاخيره وهي لا تش
محمد سيطره هي اوكرانيه لماذا لانه الحديث
عن مئات امتار في مدينه لا اعتقد انه يقدم
مدلولا عسكريا من السيطره
الانواء فايز تقول نائبه وزيره وزير
الدفاع الاوكراني ان معارك عنيفه تدور في
باخمت وان الوضع حرج ايضا المتحدث باسم
خالد الشرق الاوكرانيه قال نصده محاولات
العدو الهجوميه في جنوب غرب باخموت تصريح
نائبه وزير الدفاع عن حرج الوضع في باخمت
ربما يؤشر على قرب الاعلان عن سيطره
افاجنر عليها كما اعلن بريغوجن
يعني احنا عندما نتحدث كما قلت لك ان
نتحدث عن جزئيه
الان بالامس 1950 متر مربع اليوم قد تكون
400 متر مربع من اصل مدينه كامله هذا هذا
هو نوع من التجزئه البيان من اجل تقديم
المعلومه نهائيه بانه تمكنت القوات باكثر
من السيطره على المدينه السيطره العسكريه
والفعليه منذ اكثر من شهر نتحدث عنها ليس
الان ولكن اعتقد ان النقطه الاقوى الان
ليس الاعلان عن
سقوطات الاوكرانيه على
جنوب والشمال هذا
تنفذ عمليات هجوميه من اجل تطويق مدينه
انتقلت الان من المدينه الى اكتاف الاكتاف
الدفاعيه لهذه المدينه وهي التي ستقرر
مصير هذه المدينه في الايام والاسابيع
القادمه